comedy star of the year with like
getting a phone call like that i was
very shocked really i've been doing this
a very long time people may not know
that or not but i have
it's over 20 years of you know working
at this and many years of billy on the
street and then moving on to
other shows and i was just shocked you
know but froze is a big deal and i you
know i'm i'm so proud of it and i'm so
excited for people to see it sort of to
be acknowledged months before the movie
even comes out
it's really shocking and lovely all
right so tell me about the process of
putting this cast together in such a
beautiful story because this movie is
making history yeah it's the first gay
rom-com ever made by a major studio
the entire cast everyone's lgbtq all the
actors even in the straight roles um
strangely enough i i think i'm the first
openly gay man to ever write in star in
their own studio film is that wild yeah
and you know those facts are exciting
they're also a little
i know infuriating because you're like
it shouldn't have been me there are so
many other people who deserved it and i
just lucked out and um but because i
realized what a privilege it was i
wanted to make sure we were doing the
right thing and i wanted to be a huge
opportunity not just for me but for
other actors and so
everyone the studio nick stoller judd
apatow produced it yeah everyone got on
board with making sure the whole cast
was openly lgbtq
and it really
it's not something we talked about in
the movie of course but you can kind of
feel it in the movie it's it contributed
to the spirit of it in a way that i
think really made a difference
so you know obviously people can't wait
to see this movie but what kind of
feedback are you getting from your fans
already i have to say it's been pretty
remarkable we've started to do some
early screenings at movie theaters all
over north america and
i was petrified going into the first one
because you never know what people are
gonna think and it's the first this and
it's the first thing yeah
um but beyond all that i just wanted
people to laugh a lot i mean it's a
comedy that's the main thing forget all
the historic stuff
and people are laughing so much
they're also
um what has surprised me is how moved
people are yeah and i think it's because
when you watch it
it starts to dawn on you why haven't we
had a thousand of these yeah i know you
know and so i think people feel that and
also what i think people are realizing
is how much fun it is people have
forgotten how fun it is to sit in a
theater in the dark agree with hundreds
of other friends and strangers and eat
snacks and just laugh and escape our
awful cruel world i know for an hour and
45 minutes i think people forgot how
much fun that is and i'm telling you
it's a blast i love it what's your go-to
theater snack
oh
i love popcorn mixed with raisinets and
i love a like a gigantic diet coke which
i know will kill me but it's worth it
but it tastes so good i want to hear
what a rock star luke mcfarlane is
because i've been a fan of his for a
long time i've interviewed him so many
times being a canadian actor yeah luke
mcfarlane plays my love interest in the
movie he plays aaron and
a lot of guys every gay man in hollywood
auditioned for the role and some of them
are so wonderful
but luke came in and we just knew right
away he just
you know
he just is he's just so perfect for the
character yeah and um we had such a
great time i have so much admiration for
him because he came out as an actor long
before it was chic or something that
people celebrated and i thought that was
very brave it's not why we cast him but
i think just that added to
his story and i think he brought that
experience to the movie and
we've become friends and we've just had
a great time together and he's so great
this is really really exciting i mean
everything just feels so right about not
only this time but this movie this cast
um is it wild that the other honorees
tonight robert de niro zoe saldana like
how cool is that i know what an honor
for robert de niro to share a stage with
me tonight um it's bizarre it's
completely insane
um i don't know i'm just taking it all
in stride and
hollywood is absurd and fun and i'm so
lucky i'm beyond lucky and i'm just
trying to enjoy it and not go crazy i
love it and last question before we wrap
up my producer specifically wants to
know are you going to do like a special
edition of billy on the street in vegas
ever
not in vegas okay new york new york city
is what billy on the street's about
ultimately will we do a billy on the
street in new york anytime soon
maybe i haven't done one in a while i
know i know well congratulations sonay's
getting to talk to you